y
[Música]
inicio la cumbre entre el presidente de
eeuu joe biden y su homólogo ruso
vladimir putin en medio de profundos
desacuerdos pero con el objetivo de
apaciguar la atención a algunos de los
temas a tratar son en seguridad
informática ucrania belarús el programa
nuclear iraní y derechos humanos además
de alexéi navalni tenemos reporte desde
jinete
siguen las detenciones de críticos al
gobierno de nicaragua anoche fue
detenido el director del banco general
de producción
luís alberto rivas andura y esto pese a
que la oea aprobó una resolución y
solicitando la liberación de los
detenidos que ya son al menos 12 cuando
faltan cinco meses para las elecciones
presidenciales
y hoy es el último día de campaña
presidencial en irán en cuando faltan
dos días para las elecciones el
candidato más opcionado es ibrahim ra y
skip actual el jefe del poder judicial
conocido por su línea conservadora y
oriundo de la ciudad de mashad uno de
los primeros centros religiosos de la
nación islámica
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y del mundo aquí en tras 24
bienvenidos de nuevo yo soy liliana
valencia iniciamos este informativo en
ginebra suiza donde comenzó la cumbre
entre el presidente de eeuu joe biden y
el primer mandatario ruso vladimir putin
quienes intentarán limar asperezas y
mejorar sus relaciones en un momento de
alta tensión entre moscú y washington un
apretón de manos entre ambos mandatarios
fue el primer gesto diplomático antes de
comenzar la reunión que hoy se centra en
troy centra las miradas del mundo
putin dijo que confía en que ésta sea
productiva y bailén
a su turno señaló que siempre es mejor
verse cara a cara se espera que aborden
temas como la ciberdelincuencia el
expansionismo ruso la frontera con
ucrania medio oriente el programa
nuclear iraní entre otros ampliamos esta
información con esta enviada especial a
natalia ruiz natalia buenos días y
ustedes están villa la hagan en el
corazón de ginebra sede de este
encuentro ambos mandatarios han estado
en desacuerdo en diferentes temas cuáles
son aquellos que podrían mostrar avances
durante esta jornada
sí muy buenos días pues habrá que ver
qué tan productiva como decía a vladimir
putin resultará esta reunión
efectivamente hay muchos desacuerdos la
relación entre estos dos países viene
maltrecha ustedes tal vez recuerdan al
presidente estadounidense joe biden
diciendo calificando a su homólogo ruso
como un matón y a partir de eso fue se
hubo todavía más atenciones entre ambos
países con cada uno de estos de tanto de
rusia como eeuu llamando a consultas a
sus dos embajadores
entonces eso fuese lo que se espera es
precisamente que uno de los pasos en
adelante de estas reuniones que los
embajadores regresen cada uno a sus
puestos porque los consulados pues están
cerrados por ahora y de hecho ambos
embajadores se encuentran aquí en
ginebra y participarán en la segunda
parte de la reunión entre los dos
presidentes dentro de los puntos que
podría haber un poco más de avance tiene
que ver con cooperación una parte de lo
que es la lucha en el cambio climático
joe biden ha hablado de esto ampliamente
sobre todo en el ártico y también otra
parte es continuar las charlas en cuanto
a
no proliferación de armas nucleares se
trata de rusia y de eeuu que son las dos
mayores potencias nucleares del mundo y
si necesita que haya lo que ambas partes
han calificado de una estabilidad
estratégica es decir evitar cualquier
tipo de conflicto entre estas dos
naciones y para eso pues trata de nada
más y nada menos que de ese acuerdo new
start que ya fue prorrogado a comienzos
de este año irá hasta 2026 pero hay
nuevas negociaciones que deben comenzar
y van a demorar años para poder pues
visitar o rever todos los puntos que
quieren cada uno de los dos países pues
es la información con natalia ruiz
enviada especial de france 24 ginebra
suiza más adelante ampliaremos en las
siguientes emisiones de noticias y
cambiamos de información porque no cesan
las detenciones de críticos al gobierno
de nicaragua hay un nuevo arresto pero
esta vez no se trata de un político sino
de un banquero la policía del país
reportó en la noche del martes la
detención de luís alberto rivas anduray
director del banco general de producción
banpro la detención ocurre luego de que
la organización de estados américanos
pidiera la liberación de los cuatro
candidatos a la presidencia que han sido
arrestados en las últimas semanas y de
todos aquellos que se oponen a ortega
esas rojas nos cuenta más el es luís
alberto rivas andura y director del
banco general de la producción banpro en
nicaragua la policía del país anunció
que el banquero fue arrestado el 15 de
junio y lo acusan de conspirar contra el
estado es investigado por realizar actos
que menoscaban la independencia la
soberanía y la autodeterminación
necesitará la injerencia extranjera en
los asuntos internos en las últimas
semanas al menos 12 opositores han sido
arrestados en el marco de una nueva
legislación llamada ley de defensa de
los derechos del pueblo entre los
detenidos se encuentran incluso los
guerrilleros sandinistas dora maría
téllez y hugo torres además de cuatro
candidatos a la presidencia para las
elecciones del próximo 7 de noviembre
cristiana chamorro arturo cruz félix
maradiaga y juan sebastián chamorro el
arresto de rivas andura y ocurrió el
mismo día en que 26 de los 34 miembros
de la organización de estados
psoe-a aprobaron unas resoluciones en
las que exigieron la liberación
inmediata de los detractores detenidos
nos recuerda a esta resolución que es
necesario recuperar la democracia y el
respeto de los derechos humanos en el
país nos recuerda que la utilización de
legislación y acciones represivas y
violentas para silenciar a los medios de
prensa y la oposición se han vuelto lo
cotidiano en el país el gobierno de
daniel ortega ha dicho que este tipo de
pronunciamientos son un ataque frontal a
su soberanía y dice que está en su
derecho de investigar a los opositores
en mexico cuando faltan poco más de tres
meses para que se cumplan siete años de
la desaparición de los 43 estudiantes de
ayotzinapa las autoridades identificaron
los restos de uno de ellos apenas el
tercero todavía quedan 40 estudiantes de
magisterio en paradero desconocido entre
los 16 restos analizados por la
universidad
innsbruck de austria se dio a conocer
este martes que una vértebra lumbar
corresponde al joven josh iván y
guerrero uno de los desaparecidos en la
trágica noche del 26 de septiembre de
y continuamos en américa latina' en perú
el candidato presidencial de izquierda
pedro castillo se declaró ganador de la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales que tuvo lugar el pasado
6 de junio cuando las autoridades
electorales informaron que el 100% de
las actas ya fueron procesadas y
contabilizadas sin embargo pese a que ya
fue confirmada su ventaja sobre keiko
fujimori castillo no puede ser
proclamado presidente hasta que las
autoridades electorales revisen las
actas impugnadas por fujimori quien
denuncia fraude
soy pedro castillo terrones profesor
rondero y dirigente sindical presidente
electo de la república del perú
y aunque terminó el escrutinio en perú
por parte de la oficina de procesos
electorales el jurado nacional de
elecciones quien deberá resolver las
solicitudes de nulidad e impugnaciones
de mesas solicitadas por la candidata
keiko fujimori quien insiste sin pruebas
en que hubo fraude en el proceso
electoral más detalles el siguiente
informe
todos los votos ya han sido contados las
actas de perú arrojan que el candidato
izquierdista a la presidencia del país
petro castillo tiene el 51% de los votos
sólo cuarenta y cuatro mil cincuenta y
ocho papeletas más que su rival la
conservadora keiko fujimori sin embargo
todavía no hay un ganador oficial a la
espera de que el jurado nacional
electoral resuelva las impugnaciones
interpuestas por fujimori quien sostiene
que la estrecha victoria de castillo se
debe al fraude electoral
la tensión aumenta en las calles de perú
donde las manifestaciones de bando y
bando se suceden castillo llamó a sus
seguidores a seguir movilizándose de
manera pacífica reiteramos que no vamos
a tener no vamos nos van a encontrar
nadie ninguna agresión
pero tampoco vamos a permitir que se
siga discriminando a un pueblo oprimido
por más años
democráticamente las cosas se han puesto
en la mesa y democráticamente tiene que
darse una salida
la decisión final del jurado electoral
podría tardar días en llegar y las
autoridades peruanas tratan de hacer
respetar las reglas electorales del país
rechazamos todo discurso o acto que
suponga el desconocimiento de los
resultados electorales que habrá de
anunciar oficial y oportunamente la
autoridad electoral y de cualquier
intento de afectar el orden
constitucional mientras tanto los
peruanos siguen sin saber quién ocupará
la presidencia más de una semana después
de acudir a las urnas
la unión europea anunció su decisión de
permitir nuevamente el ingreso de
viajeros provenientes de eeuu incluso
sin estar vacunados y de otros cinco
países en un paso más hacia la des
escalada de las medidas contra el 19 con
esto el bloque incluye la unión
americana en su lista de naciones
seguras desde el punto de vista
epidemiológico ahora los ciudadanos
americanos pueden viajar a europa por
turismo y nosotros por motivos de fuerza
mayor los otros cinco países incluidos
en la lista son albania líbano macedonia
del norte serbia y taiwán
último día de campañas a la presidencia
de irán este miércoles dos candidatos se
retiraron de la carrera electoral a dos
días de las presidenciales nuestra
corresponsal en este país catalina gómez
ángel nos envía un reporte de la ciudad
de mashad que fue uno de los principales
centros religiosos de irán junto con com
y que por años lideró la política en el
país tanto el líder supremo como el
portavoz del parlamento son demasiado
la tripleta que podría completar en
estas elecciones donde hay tres
candidatos de esta ciudad los une a
todos su visión conservadora del país
la existencia al mausoleo del imam reza
hace de marcha del principal centro de
peregrinaje de irán
miles de familias como la el hoy
director del mausoleo llegaron de otras
partes del país para vivir cerca de la
tumba del octavo imán de los chiítas
lo que tenemos es gracias a las buenas
intenciones de nuestros padres aquí la
vida gira en torno al mausoleo
la economía es prospera gracias a
millones de peregrinos
y desde esta tribuna al principal
ayatolá de la ciudad
a la moda dictan las reglas sociales más
estrictas que en otras partes de irán
algunas de las principales figuras
religiosas han estado educadas en mashad
como el líder supremo de la revolución
más chata es la contraparte de teherán
que lidera la apertura social en irán en
esta ciudad impera en las ideas
conservadoras y recelosas de occidente
que se imponen en el escenario político
actual tres de los candidatos más
radicales a estas elecciones son
demasiado incluido el principal
opcionado el clérigo ebrahim raisi bombo
de raíz y es un hombre correcto que
busca ayudar a la gente
lejos del mausoleo hay otras visiones
del mundo
hay un grupo de gente y el gobierno
están hechos el uno para el otro
uno hace parte de un gran número de
artistas que se mover en espacios
alternativos
la vida de la mayoría de irán no es como
se venderán en países mucho más mucho
más los pequeños cambios sociales que se
ven en espacios como estos cafés han
sido presionados por los jóvenes pero
hay todavía cientos de actividades
prohibidas como los conciertos la
entrada de dinero de otras actividades
como conciertos no son necesarios para
el gobierno local porque van a arriesgar
el sello religioso de la ciudad para
hacer
a poca gente feliz las normas no dejan
que artistas como me puedan vivir de lo
que ganan con la música así lo dejan de
intentarlo
[Música]
isra lanzó un nuevo ataque contra gaza
poniendo fin a la tregua con el grupo
islamista hamás que entró en vigor el 21
de mayo pasado la ofensiva responde al
lanzamiento de globos incendiarios por
parte de seguidores del grupo islamista
hamás justamente que a su vez rechazaron
la denominada marcha de las banderas
donde mire desde un re nacionalistas
israelíes se tomaron las calles de la
disputada ciudad de jerusalén del este
fin a la tregua las explosiones
nocturnas volvieron a iluminar los
cielos en la franja de gaza tras un
ataque del ejército israelí que asegura
respondía a hostilidades del grupo
islamista hamás
activamos una unidad nocturna para
apoyar a nuestra gente en jerusalén
y nos molestaremos en respuesta a la
marcha de las banderas
horas antes del ataque aéreo cientos de
ultranacionalistas israelíes salieron a
las calles de jerusalén esté despertando
la ira de los palestinos
vinimos aquí para decirle a hamás que el
estado de israel es el señor de la
tierra de jerusalén no sucumbiremos a
sus invitados ni a sus amenazas
los lanzamientos ponen a prueba la paz
en la región acordada tras 11 días de
intercambios bélicos que dejaron 225
muertos en gaza y 13 en israel con la
mediación de egipto y las presiones de
varios gobiernos entre ellos el de joe
biden así como la respuesta que dará el
nuevo gobierno de nafta live net el
conflicto se había reanudado el 10 de
mayo tras días de enfrentamientos entre
manifestantes palestinos y la policía de
israel cerca de la mezquita al-aqsa un
lugar sagrado para judíos y musulmanes
jamás disparó cohetes hacia jerusalén
israel respondió según la onu unos 58
mil palestinos han huido de sus hogares
desde entonces refugiándose en escuelas
de naciones unidas'
así finalizamos por esta emisión hembras
24 pero ustedes también pueden visitar
nuestro sitio web con información del
acontecer internacional en cuatro
idiomas nuevos más adelante con más
información
[Música]